jace imagine the first people to ever
step on a train and I may like the first
kinds of trains that were ever made
those people must have been like oh my
god doesn't mean they had like been
walking it may be most back riding for
their whole lives and they must have
thought this technology is amazing if we
just build rails everywhere we can go
everywhere others
Vala the sky is the limit you know and
maybe there was a little physicist on
that train I'm allowed to make fun of
physicists because I am one and maybe he
said that a case of the more code I put
into the engine
the faster the train goes but then he
made made a little line between his
points and then perhaps he extrapolated
wildly and said that it's my build an
infinitely large engine and put an
infinite amount of coal into the engine
can this train go infinitely fast and
that we can sort of chuckle a bit and
say that yeah no no it can't because you
have but some architectural limitations
going on there's quite a lot of
frictions and your radials and there is
air resistance in front of your train
and then also there are physical
limitations that you just never know
about you have just the sound barrier
that you're gonna bump into and the
nature this speed of light also show so
no trains again but you can't you can't
go infinitely fast for them and I'm
looking at this little block does that
remind you of anything in AI discussions
if I change the axis labels that there
is this funny thing going on where we
think that we just keep throwing
processing power at our problems and at
our machines then intelligence will pop
out and inspire my little train example
can we think something like yeah we
don't have any indication
so general intelligence poking out of
anything yet and if you think about the
one general intelligence we know oh
that's us right that's our brains and
our brains there's nothing like the
remaining machines not the same at all
and then there's more of its paradox
which was actually formulated already in
the 80s which says that high-level
reasoning requires primitive processing
power so there is definitely something
more going on there
and also for all we know there might be
physical realization students I don't
believe that personally I think carbon
is physics special but you know for all
we know there may be limitations in our
processors and transistors that we still
have to pump into so I think it's
important I'm not insinuating that any
of you are scared of a GI but much of
the public discussions are centered
around them because it's easy to make
anyone's with it well I think that what
we need to do is to take those
discussions down to the systems that we
are currently making machine learning
and stuff that we call nei and then we
have to think about what can what can go
wrong and what you're going to worry
about and what can go really well with
these systems that we're building right
now so thinking about your your job in
AI and machine learning what you can
actually do with that is contribute to
build a better world if you states
analysis is definitely
in the world right there is no arguing
about that and today I want to share
some of my kind of most recent thoughts
on this and what we have to take really
seriously of what we have to discuss and
so right now there's our two top things
and the first topic is the kata because
as you all know there is no machine
learning without data and also
unfortunately you have this effect of so
let's be inspired by machine learning
and look at the past is this something
to learn there and yes I think actually
if we go all the way back to the 1400 in
Venice this is guy called Luca and he's
known as me it can change who changed
the world but you don't hear that often
pirate captains changing the world but
what he did was he went to this thing
called double-entry bookkeeping
it's a marvelous system because when an
action starts the day when you have
consist so what is supposed to do is
write down how much gold he has and how
much he has a container of whatever you
cells and every time he makes the
transaction so every time they sell
something he's supposed to write down a
new number of gold coins in good study
hands and I feel like if obviously you
should do that when you're running your
business this just like washing your
hands after touching something filthy
before hitting this has to be invented
this was so powerful that it changed the
world that creates it more than finance
based on on this and the reason it can
change the world is to thought one thing
is that it just works really really well
it's easy to enormous bag analogous
works right before this people basically
kept Diaries so in the morning they
would open the store and then just do
their things and in the evening they
were advised from the diary
I stayed sun shining now I have listened
as many gold coins the meaning they they
they had no chance of doing that data
analysis which good so well and maybe if
somebody was disappearing for different
reasons themselves and also this
happened at a very opportune moment at
the right time at the right place
because Venice was pretty much a center
a global center for trade and Finance
meaning that anybody who traded with
these guys who used the system were
inspired and kind of incentivized to
also use it and you might have heard of
the Medici bank Medici is it's Italian
it's plural for medical medical doctor
and this poor guy up there was the first
we know of the Medicare so he was doctor
from pretty low class lived outside of
Venice and he decided I'm gonna go into
banking instead and he was one of the
first guys who started to using this
standardized formats and before he died
he was like the most powerful rich
person on the planet I mean he founded
this village bank avicii empire who was
so silly rich that they basically paid
for the whole Renaissance because they
wanted art thanks to standardized system
which was easy to use and which nobody
had thought about and taking more recent
example you know containers ships this
pretty much revolutionized the shipping
industry because before containers all
floating a chef you take a week now that
takes about an hour I could grab a
container through Don trainer off it
goes now imagine the future you can say
I would used to take them weeks to get
all the data for my project now it takes
me an hour so that's that's kind of
brain explodes kind of amazing to think
about it's pretty utopian but it is
definitely the future that we are and
half
be working towards if we want to build a
data driven society and actually on
their on the train going to the airport
on my way here I was scrolling around on
LinkedIn and I stumbled across this
Netflix blog where the Netflix paid the
scientists they're pretty good nights
huh
where they say that some of the hardest
things by working as data scientists and
Netflix a difficulty is related to the
x-axis data processing and probably also
data governance issues and this made me
think about this in kind of a third way
because when I talk data scientists they
say that well I spent did besides us are
expensive right now and they spend a
little time on mundane data tasks which
I hate which take my energy away and
companies have to pay for that also very
often what companies do is that they
structure the data piece wise like you
know I need now I want insight from this
data so make a data warehouse and
structure this and then maybe they don't
do that for the rest of the dates and
they're going around there's a lot of
lost value in all the dates about that
won't be analyzed and then now and then
from that face to best benefit to this
we have your dates an order you're
definitely going to attract the best day
to scientists out there but that's very
much patient I don't know what is but an
uplifting thought here even though I
know that probably most of you and I
also hate little names of struggles the
labeling in the day time getting the
nature in the right order and then
getting a lot of errors because my
matrix wasn't in the right format but if
you turn around this thing and just
think about what we're actually doing is
we're preparing the world from morons
in future and in this effort
global data science communities open
source codes and meetings like this are
immensely important because it is
important that we know go around
inventing the wheel and reinventing
solutions like on our own on our
learning job it's important a bit full
than the right in the same direction and
learn from each other's mistakes and
promises and we're definitely heading in
the right direction there's some pretty
confident that will land on common data
standards just like the Medici is you
know we're both great things will come
out of this but in the meantime fourth
or once we saw the data issues and said
there are still other things that can
ruin this for us and you can summarize
that I think in misuse and misuse of the
tools that we built I mean I almost
think that it's even worse to think
about the tools we could have built and
don't built for various reasons the
places were human beings do tasks that
AI or machines could have done a lot
more efficiently and a lot better and
humans have gotten that stuff they would
rather like to do but there's also being
misuse aspects which is using error in a
bad way being unethical and also using
AI in the wrong way is just thinking
that it does one thing but then it's
actually doing another thing that looks
pretty similar and then we just start
off this I would like to finish there a
bit of a cute example which I have to
tell you about the pizza chain which is
like Scandinavians most popular best
watching it's called Pete's
and there and what they tried to do at
some point is that they're trying to do
no not going to stop there what they did
is that they put up a pretty ugly
advertisement sign of the main train
station about swimmers the capital of
Norway and it was our view because as
you can see nothing wouldn't frame with
the home at the top
but nobody really noticed and it was
like show me pizza but then suddenly
something went wrong with the sign and
it started sharing things like male 20s
zero went forth and then it said female
1306 so what was actually happening the
reason for the ugly hole that the frame
was that there was a camera and that the
camera was doing facial detection the
gender and age group of people and then
measuring how long people would look at
which products
so basically stuff like well it will
demand important people movement look
more at solids and this is kind of
nothing new it's just that before facial
recognition what this beats a chain
would have done is hire a consultant
made him hide in the bushes and then he
would here was actually estimated gender
and age group this advertisement site
recorded less information about people
on the consulting would have done right
because he would have remembered the
people but still no we just hated this
they were still angry I mean this was in
the newspapers all over the place all
right sir but if this hadn't been kept a
speed set which we really love if it
would have been a small chain or a
foraging this would have been a
reputational disaster especially because
people are still skeptical you know
towards robots making decisions and
automated decision making and
surveillance is this this was kind of
surveillance right I mean you can't
blame people because when we hear about
AI and surveillance we hear a bunch of
big things but used to go literature
which is now actually and I think that
most likely remember conversations I
have about AI these days mentioned China
what they're doing in some form or other
and it's pretty clear to me that when I
know what they're doing is right when
you think about it what do we mean by
ethical by ethical we mean our ethics
I'm gonna be a bit course they're just
divided into eastern and western ethics
if you think about the eastern ethics
begin their journeys ethical models
there are no there's no Aristotle Plato
circuit isn't there I mean they're the
good life good life right that's the
game of ethics then the kid's life is
determined by how you live in relation
to all the people that's not how I think
our ethical model is I'm free to do what
I decide with my life and my date said
if you wanted you have to ask me to pay
for it but that's my registration model
that's what gdpr is based upon now
they're they're they're two facts and we
just really have to be be aware about
one is one thing is that this Eastern
data sharing moment whether you like it
or not is just perfect grants for
building machine learning moments
obviously lots of models that's where
they are staying
and the other thing is that me owning my
data it is easier for Google and
Facebook to ask for my data than it is
for instance for the Norwegian
healthcare system because give me on
Facebook it's just better at asking our
questions so I'm actually sharing more
of my decks with people who want you to
earn money from me or corporations who
are
for me then the corporation's who want
to like help me if I ever get canceled
this is a problem we need to solve
I mean nationally or preferably in in
all of Europe and and I think we really
need to say to the discussion down from
my I was scared of what's going on in
China at that to you but what are we
trying to achieve right there this is
the discussion we need to happen we need
to lift the discussion up to people
they're not technical you don't know too
much about AI and just go like hey your
data can be used together this is this
brings us into more of an FX discussion
because si ethics is not just about what
you do with things out but what you do
with the algorithms afterwards also and
it seems to me like 2019 has been a bit
of a later year for AI ethics and that
is good like we're already talking about
it not only that browse for making
ethics committees and ethical guidelines
which is good but I think there's there
are weaknesses in these ethics
committees and ethics boards that are
being put up one of them is that they
tend to break up the other thing is that
sometimes guidelines come out of them or
usually dryvax come out to them they're
pretty high flying in wishy-washy and
it's impossible to know what you're
supposed to implement from them and also
very often they don't address the
questions that for me
implementing this AI on record to get
answered and I want to illustrate that
but one example which is favorite bad
guy in these days bias making headlines
like never before
and then this this in this Amazon case
this happened right because they trained
on some populations and they
inadvertently made the assumption this
population
for the population I want in the future
that wasn't the thing is that by is
really just a different word for
predictor you wish hadn't been used when
I am talking about saying people people
and they go back again can you make it
context algorithm work are you sure that
it's unbiased like no no biases
information it's if you take out both by
use you take out all the pretty clear
power right
what you mean is will its discriminate
against groups you don't want
discriminated against so we actually we
have to be a bit more precise I mean
it's okay that the head legs go back
algorithm was biased but when we would
background the statistics try to fix
this we have to be a bit more precise
and it's not as easy as over an
underrepresented groups I mean here this
Amazon training said probably something
biased going off there but you can have
a perfectly balanced training dates on
the same thing gets done happen we have
a fairly recent example here from the US
healthcare system so they saw that any
we have a lot of element people waiting
in orange to be treated now let's sort
this line in a good way so the blue most
urgent cases this year
get medical attention possible what
ended up happening was that a little
more white people got treatment before
black people how can that be when the
training days that was was balanced well
it was basically because of the mention
of the last function because what they
were asking average is predict was how
much will this patient cost in our scan
system and for historical and cultural
reasons why patients have been more
expensive for the healthcare system well
obvious reasons so this should be easily
circumvented
changing the tradition to instead how
often was a medical condition reoccur
and then suddenly the discrimination was
gone so and if this is a very important
point to think about it's not as simple
as is it in Tibet biased or not I mean
your data contains the maximum amount of
information and that is up to you what
you do with model that comes out of the
data and what you ask your mom to
predict to illustrate this father of
artificial intelligence Marvin Minsky
once went in to the office of one of his
students and asked them what are you
doing and the students that well I'm
training someone singlets and I'm
randomly initializing in the ways so
that the bias will be gone a Minsky when
he closed his eyes and the student was
like when you close your eyes they miss
he said supermoon will be on see these
you can't make boys go away there
anything you could use be aware of it
and mitigate it and actually AI and
automated decision ease is good news
right now because the bias and
discrimination has already been here
what AR it does is systemizing it so
that you can see when it happens
systemically instead of a bunch of
judges being racist and biased on their
own and maybe not even noticing that
they are we get these uncomfortable
headlines and we see that there are some
systemic and fairness going on and there
we go
you can have a public discussion about
it and we can fix it because fortunately
it's easier to change algorithms than it
is to change people
however bias is not even the most
difficult part of the discussion because
we have this thing called fairness and
fairness is a societal construct but is
one thing what one society deems is fair
is different from what another society
deems as bad and also different fairness
definitions are very often mutually
exclusive as I'd like to illustrate this
using another example from the US from
there just modulus which is very calm
pass there know if you've heard about
this is this algorithm those first two
how judges decide whether a defendant
should go to jail while defending trial
or not so what basically does it
calculates a risk score like some kind
of probability of the defendant doing
something stupid while awaiting that
trial now of course this algorithm is
not trained on this Nyssa t could it
still have racial bias what do you think
here thinks that it could have racial
bias I want to see all of your hands go
up yeah yeah it might as well you know
be an ethnicity predictor because there
are social differences be cultural
differences between white and black
people in the United States and that's
just the way it is so what the algorithm
does as I said is it calculates risk
score and that risk score you use in
each single individual defendant to
decide whether they should go to jail or
not now unfortunately people aren't all
that easy to predict so that picture is
not going to be like this it's not going
to be like you can find a perfect list
above which everybody should be jailed
and everybody else should be less
anything stupid right reality with the
human beings is a bit more like this
you're gonna put some people into prison
that you shouldn't have put into prison
and you're gonna then add some people
who will end up committing crimes of
which you should have put into prison
that's also just the way it is but the
uncomfortable headlines show up when
this effective that whites and black
people are just two different groups in
my day term whether we like it or not
and it turns out that these whites and
black people are jailed with different
frequencies the other question is what
would be the fastening to do what the
fans think be wrongfully in prison
black and white people at the same
frequencies or is the fair thing to do
to treat one individual and with the
same risks or with one risk scoring the
same way independent of their skin
colour I mean both of these sounds bad
right things have reduced the same
response of black and white people what
happens is that a lot more black than
what people are needed to be jailed and
that's what generating the headlines
right imprisoning a lot of black people
are not white people what is this this
is obviously racist this is unfair but
the problem is if you want to change
this without changing like Society what
you can do is you can have different
risk scores for the different
ethnicities meaning that black people
that will jail at higher risk or than
white people but the problem then is
that you're literally discriminating
right because you treat two people
differently based only on their
ethnicity and that is actually forbidden
by law so what we see here is that we
have two famous definitions that are
just mutually exclusive you're going to
be fair individuals here or Chur groups
but you can't do both at the same time
that's going on here there are you as a
developer or a statistician are they the
scientist you're going to notice this
when you try to implement your systems
and have your fairness security
trade-offs there is you should not be
put into the position where you have to
make these decisions I mean what is
there in my society that has to be
defined by a democratic process right I
mean this is a political decision it's
not central decisions the problem is
that it's we technical people who
discover these problems meaning that
when we do it's very important that we
list these discussions up I mean these
are the discussions I wish were making
headlines instead but they at least they
have to go like you know to your boss
jumping over to to my first and actually
my my favorite discussion in AI is that
understanding what's going on as I said
I'm a physicist I think it's very
important to understand what's going on
underneath having an algorithm which
makes good predictions is like yeah
that's very nice but if I don't know why
it's making good decisions I don't know
for how long it will continue seeing
that some samples from a new
distribution and also there's this old
causality discussion so to the strength
it is actually in fact that babies that
are born too early have a high chance
for survival it's the mother smoked
during pregnancy and I when you hear
that you know like you know because
smoking is
healthy Asian smoke during pregnancy the
trick is that smoking during pregnancy
can be a reason for babies to be more
Charlie so that means that if you as a
baby or born too early it's good for you
if it is because your mother smirched
but it doesn't would have been better if
she didn't smoke if you want book
charlie
the thing is that no matter how much
data processing power you throw at this
problem today's machine learning systems
will not figure out this causation for
you right cuz what is machine I mean she
and having is here you have a bunch of
data making model and give me a
prediction now I think that the one
prediction is a bit of an exaggeration
because you can make you know if you can
predict the future it sounds like you've
understood the causal connections of the
cosmos am i right you understand what
causes what that's no one machine
learning there's machine learning or
machine learning model but it doesn't it
takes the data sample and goes back what
does this remind you
and then basically puts it on some side
of the decision surface or into old and
to a cluster of whatever it's mostly
like so I'm not saying that we should
all change the word to be used but
perhaps think about machine learning and
predicting more as Association now that
is not to say that machine learning is
not powerful I mean just think you think
about some of the feeds that machine
learning has achieved
I actually might like my favorite
achievement from from any machine
learning module is when deep blue or
equally now deep zero keep beating him
being success and it's not so doing but
okay so the first time when Garry
Kasparov was beaten by deep blue that
was the first time he was beaten at all
he had never lost again before that and
he said it was so devastating it hurt
physically
you know that but when he got over it he
said the way he got over it was by
thinking that you know numerical
statistical different optimization of
problems is always going to be human
beings in a closed system think about
that just if you zoom up far enough the
world is actually a closed system right
if we get some energy from the Sun with
low absolute here but our problems all
exist inside a closed system and very
many of them can be solved by using
prediction well but using them well
that's really the key word because we
who are literally these days creating
our AI future we have to remember what
machine learning does is correlation
detection machine learning Disney to
understand the context in which it
operates it doesn't understand what is
normal rights it's really just a tool
blanket change so we still have to do
the thinking for it and I think you have
to be very very ambitious regarding
understanding what's going on I think I
didn't get to talk about explainable
anyway today but I really hope for that
is going to be filled with a lot of
focus and even there now it's difficult
to get deep neural networks and say that
ok so here I had 7000 dimensional
feature space if I was able to actually
describe this analytically that would
mean I had solved the curse of
dimensionality and I wouldn't use
machine learning in the first place
that's ok but still let's try to be
ambitious and let's try to understand
what's actually going on because that's
where intelligence and intelligence lies
and down as far as I know we're the only
intelligent ones here right that's what
I read today thank you very much for
listening
[Applause]
thank you yeah faux fur talk questions
yeah thanks in the it was a nice
presentation I just have one question
about your ethics let's say if tomorrow
Palestine got AI stuff and the Hamas do
you think they will even blink for a
second to strike Jerusalem within a
second as per your saying that we should
have to be all intelligent we sure have
to be all good do you think it will
happen in near future okay
repeating again do you think I mean
you're talking about the ethics and the
data you're also saying that machine
learning is nothing is just a tool but
for Teta engineers machine learning is
the religion as this is our only one
particular tool for which we can help
the human society but as you're saying
about the ethics if tomorrow Hamas or
Palestine get any AI tool do you think
they even think for a second to strike
Jerusalem and they are are or in this
case that when Cambridge analytical took
the data from Norwegian data centers and
helped Donald Trump to be the President
of the United States noting what
happened to ethics at that time but then
[Music]
and I like cause I mean the the course
for our problems are in our past and our
human-made right so it's it's just like
going from there you call it poison
arrows to machine guns it's it's not
that we now have a more powerful to I
don't suppose you can use it as a weapon
or you can use it to make good things
but what would that happen is it's
really independent of what is it depends
on people as as a date engineer you you
can't make that choice but what happens
to the ethics depends on what the people
in power
questions the way to affect this
decision is what do you think like what
does anybody think well I am not
satisfied with your answer because the
way you started the presentation and
then you completed it it's like a white
angle we called we call as two pi in our
mathematics thanks to can you repeat
asked 2pi degree great ravages made
possible by AI and some all of these
challenges we have to address like a
society through our democratic process
but very many of them are challenges we
have to make society aware of because we
are the first ones to spot them because
we understand the technical aspects of
this agree understand exactly what we
need to program into to avoid one thing
to happen
or which fairness methods metric to use
because it just Boyd's them to be the
statistics so I'm not saying that we
have to solve the ethical problems I'm
saying that we have grave responsibility
in making society aware of them and
exactly how they okay hold on I have a
tiny problem with democratic process is
the best way of making decision nowadays
but if you for example ask people I
don't know hundred hundred years ago if
women should vote and if it's good they
will probably say that it's wrong so
it's kind of problematic - yeah like of
course I understand that this is the
best way probably to make that decision
but still I'm not satisfied with it so
it's good to have discussions of course
we should rise the awareness and show
the issue to other people but one
wouldn't be enough probably one more
question for coffee break what I would
like to come back to the presentation
and to the last part of it so you
mentioned that we mistake we mistakenly
claimed that the correlation is the
causality and I think this is the part
of the bias so do you think we can apply
the models we can develop the models
that try to find causal eating not
correlation in deep learning
[Music]
it can be used combined with machine
learning to try to find causation
but I think it possibly can find also of
course the human domain expertise so
what I meant was that the statistic and
achromat econometrics are half meters
for finding causality and so can we dip
take on it somehow apply seamstick so
economists can just find the
correlations problem and then I come
from physics and physics I know that
there is unwinding everything so I just
need to find the both nature in there
there is probably PDF of the universe
schools that need to communicate better
now answer your question I can never
have believed it